i mean like star wars right like i'm
such a huge star wars fan
and i'm so sorry for your life the woke
culture
that destroyed star wars just
i could never get over the last jedi i'm
on that side
i haven't watched it since it came out
the night i watched that and all the
woke culture i'm just like
why star wars isn't about woke culture
star wars is about
family drama things going on luke had
daddy issues anakin good versus
evil leia she kissed her brother
people could relate to that i guess but
what about this weird woke stuff that's
all of a sudden i'm like
why did you do this to star wars
sometimes i cry
but i really was pissed i don't think
the last jedi got uh
super woke a lot of people say that i'm
like sure they had dude with the purple
hair
yeah yeah yeah yeah but that's true lady
man admiral generously over the place
like women were dominating they had poe
look like a [ __ ]
you know it was weird it was weird bro
and it just it just wasn't good
like they demeaned all the men luke
skywalker was just a nobody
look at look at we've talked about this
a million times back when pop culture
still existed
now everything's just you know antifa
and trump but uh let's talk pop culture
dude everything's invaded right now ever
so
so a really good example of what
counters the last jedi is
wonder woman in wonder woman the men
were were badass and so was she and so
were the amazons
it was a bunch of heroic people of all
different types that's all that mattered
and then you look at and it was a good
movie it was you know like john boyega
he complains
oh uh i think my character wasn't that
well because
you know i'm black right i'm like no
it's because the screen yeah it's
because the screenwriters suck
it's because the movie the story just
was not great it wasn't good it's not
because
the color of your skin don't take it
personally dude i got to tell you man
i've watched a bunch of movies where i'm
just like i don't understand why this is
the direction they went in
you know so i just watched uh the new
bill and ted have you seen the new bill
and ted not yet
and i'm kind of like they almost got me
mad
so i don't i can't spoil the movie
because i did like it
and canada reeves is awesome he's always
awesome and it was bill and ted 3 and it
was funny yeah
i don't think it was as good as the
first two because i think it was like a
nostalgia thing
i don't want to spoil it but they do
dive into sjw
i can't say what it is because the movie
just came out but i but they they they
it looks like they're nose diving and
i'm like you can't be serious and they
pull it back and i'm like all right
that's okay i guess
because it they i'll just put it this
way it almost negates
like retcons the original movies yeah
you know bill you know you're familiar
with that yeah
so they they they added a change and i'm
just like don't don't you do it don't
you oh
it kind of yeah i think millennials will
relate to this it's like we love
authentic things
i just love anything that's authentic if
it's handmade
whatever if it's made digitally but you
made it like i love it and it's like
the stories nowadays they're not
authentic they're engineered even george
lucas hit on this like all of the
stories all hollywood
everything's engineered it's pre-planned
just for ratings just for the box office
how much money is it gonna make we make
decisions based off of money and that's
what happened in star wars and it's like
why can't i just have an authentic
amazing story
that uplifts my soul and doesn't make me
feel bad for not being not woke enough
like it's like this always
i'm being guilt-tripped always in every
movie every tv every podcast
everything that's in wolt culture it's
like you're not woke enough
so you need to be more woke and if
you're not going to be woke enough
then you're a racist and it's like why
is that our media now why is that holly
that's
that's cultural antifa mm-hmm you know
what i mean cultural marxism
so i i mean i i don't want to call it
that
what what is that what is that school of
thought that talks about it it's the
something school i don't remember
look i look at this as you've got the
the physical and the more abstract
in the physical world you have far left
just going around burning things down
destroying things screaming
and they're like commander red falling
into the fetal position frankfurt school
frankfurt sorry you put me on the spot
there i forgot what it was and then you
have
in in the cultural spaces they're
burning down and destroying
cultural institutions and icons and and
and uh
art social norms i look at
uh the the example of my go to probably
i think i
already referenced it earlier is into
the spider verse you saw that movie
right
it's it's relatable i'm i'm not i'm not
a afro-latino kid growing up in the in
the city
but he's a regular kid going through
things that where i'm just like
i can understand this and i think about
these movies that do really bad
like the last jedi think about sitting
around with your friends
male and female black and white asian
mexican whatever
latino and you're like i don't know
anybody who acts like that
like the men in like the dudes i hang
out with aren't bumbling morons who hate
women
yeah dude i had i i had exactly i
i've had an sjw like that i worked with
asked me how many of my male friends are
okay with rape they think this way
then they make movies based off of these
psychotic assumptions
like have you ever met a man and like
hung out with them
it's like i'm sitting here i'm a dude
i'm in front of you what makes you think
i would feel that so it's insane to ask
yeah but they they read these things
online they read these garbage articles
they get these these lectures and then
they create this world view that doesn't
exist
so it's almost like we're talking about
propaganda earlier with like antifa
there's they they live they live in this
world that's been manufactured
it's almost like imagine if people were
running around with harry potter robes
and flicking wands at people screaming
voldemort was coming yep
that's that that's the same thing as far
as i'm concerned yeah because that's
their ideology and they've they've
bought into the lie
that donald trump is the leader of the
oncoming fourth reich
like so people no i want people to
understand like these people honestly
believe
they honestly believe i do believe they
truly believe it they do believe that
they're fascists they believe donald
trump is a fascist they believe the
fourth reich is coming
this is why they do what they do so
they're always on the offense
they're always on the offense because of
that and that's why they do what they do
and people need to understand like
why why why you know like you described
earlier why what do you mean they'll
just run up to someone accuse them to be
a nazi and just beat them up because
their ideology
has trained them to believe that there's
an enemy out there that wants to put
them in gulags there's an enemy out
there
they want to do that exactly they're
projecting on that they
are they are history
right stalin whenever whenever
communists would subvert
another country when they would target
another country
who would the communists pose as in that
country
anti-fascists right and they would do
that
they would claim to be the very thing
that they are defending
against i'm not sure they are trying to
produce
i'm not a historian but i was reading an
article on the internet which you know
everything makes me an expert you're
familiar with the fascists
that you know what it is can you do can
you describe it like what like uh
the fascists like what it is the little
it's a it's uh
i'm not trying to put you on the spot
i'm trying i'm trying to make a point by
highlighting things
but i'll just throw it to you yeah i
know what it is
fashions whatever it's like a bundle of
sticks
and they're considered stronger when
they're together i guess or something
something so this i was reading an
article about the
the symbolism and so the fascist is
a it's a bunch of it's a weapon with
like a axe blade and a bunch of sticks
strapped together all those together
make it strong and you know what the
revolution fist is
you know why they hold it forward so you
can see it
they don't they don't raise their fist
like this to you they turn their fist
like that
so you can see the fingers together make
a strong fist
it's it's very very similar it's an
authoritarian collectivist
symbol so i'll tell you when i see
people walking up to
patrons at a diner and they're all
raising the fist into their faces
and screaming salute us i'll tell you
what that reminds me of
and that not it's not going to make me
think trump is the fascist yeah it's not
good
that's the lie they're posing they they
are posing
as to what they're going to implement
and they accuse their enemy as being who
they are
so you don't see it coming and that is
straight out of olinsky right
yeah have you seen the book in defense
of looting
back during ferguson when they were
looting all the stores and
and you know burning everything down
somebody wrote an article because there
was a lot of press coming out saying all
this looting and writing and destruction
is bad
especially in a community like ferguson
that it's a black community and part of
it not all of it
some part of ferguson was actually
really really wealthy but it was
impoverished black homes by burning and
destroying it down
there was the obvious criticism you're
actually hurting the black community
wow so some far left just wrote an
article called in defense of looting
and they said that it was you know uh
stealing back from the oppressors and
all those other garbage nonsense it
wasn't true because the locals hated the
looting
and they were like you burned down our
hair supply store like there's a salon
and like a hair supply
where people would go to get like things
for their hair to get their hair done
and stuff they burn it down
and then you hear the the next lie is
but they have insurance
and the insurance does not cover this
stuff in saints uh uh in
the twin cities there's a story coming
out now where apparently
they insurance only covers 25 up to 25
000
of rubble removal and the total cost was
like 140 k for some bill
for some buildings so they're out they
can't they can't afford to pay 115k back
to
for the removal so they're just done
they walk away it makes sense like from
a marxist standpoint you know if
you believe that capitalism is evil if
you believe that the free market is evil
if you believe that private property is
like an abomination
to humanity it makes sense to me that
you have a bunch of people out here
that are willing to torch buildings in
the name of their ideology so to me
it just makes total sense yeah any
building doesn't matter who it doesn't
matter it doesn't
to me if i try and think like that i'm
like dude if i'm a marxist and i don't
believe any of that then
i think that it's evil then it makes
total sense that these people are
running around burning anything they can
get their hands on
so if these people are all crazy violent
are you you get scared when you go down
there and you know that you're gonna
but let me get specific not just cover
this but you've actually ridden in
vehicles with them
you've actually hung out with them yeah
i've been physically assaulted
uh they they tried to rip my mask off
rip my helmet off
um i'm more worried
about the mentally ill people that are
out there they are out there there's
people that are mentally ill
they're mentally unstable you can see it
you can hear it and you could hear them
making threats to the police too like
they'll be like i have a knife and i'm
not afraid to use it i have a knife and
i'm not afraid to use it
the unpredictable aspect of that
is what worries me the most um the
strategic stuff
i have intel i know how they move i know
how they work
um i've been briefed on certain things
but it's the unpredictable people that
that that's dangerous because someone
could just come out of nowhere and not
even think things through like there's
not even a reason like you said earlier
you know they come up they could stab
you they could shoot you that's kind of
what
is uh got me looking on my six when i'm
out there i mean like the dude in
portland
doesn't seem to be all with it like the
guy who killed that trump supporter
like easily manipulated unwell
you take some of these people who have
built this world view where they're
screaming nazi all over
like and you can easily manipulate them
and doing whatever you want
this is it it's the only way he's the
one right here yeah
you said it's useful idiots i mean but
it's beyond idiot
you know like a useful idiot you get
some guy who doesn't realize that the
railroad he's building is going to be
used for
concentration exactly so but these these
people are usefully mentally ill to the
to the far left
so an example of a useful idea is
something that andy called out earlier
today and i was like he's dropping some
serious shade because there was a
journalist who was sitting there in
portland he was like
look this whole city's on fire and
there's like people walking by in the
park he's like i was like okay first of
all so that's trump's america is this
what we're referring to
again just checking but andy made the
point that antifa is depending on people
who
are useful idiots like this guy so
he's not someone who's actively engaged
he's just running
you know he's running interference for
them he's covering for them yep he's he
he hears his friends in the office
saying antifa's not that bad and then he
laughs and says
look at this it's a park and um when i
saw when i saw a lot of these
a lot of these posts are going around
where they're like they claim portland
is burning but like
i'm here eating a cheeseburger and
everything's okay that's how it is in
most conflict
yeah like you you you realize like
you're not going to walk into
a civil unrest urban conflict or civil
war and
people just are all dead like i'm sure
there's places where that's happened you
know the bomb gets dropped or something
but if if you realize people have to
keep eating so they have to keep working
and food has to keep shipping and means
trucks are still driving and it means
one of the craziest things about this
this narrative too is during the
the like the height of the syrian civil
war the syrian tourism board was still
advertising for nightlife in damascus
wow we were trying to do it as
back when i was advised we were trying
to do a documentary on it and i guess
they said it was in poor taste or
something
and i was like dude it's not about going
and partying and laughing at
the misery it's going there and showing
that there are people partying on
rooftops
with like music and and like
miles away to explosions and like sarin
gas attacks
like it's an example of how life goes on
now people are scared people are worried
there are checkpoints there's terrorists
all this stuff
is happening but they're still dancing
to like that hot club remix
you know but these useful idiots well
because there's people that want nothing
to do with it
you know like in portland there there
are people that want nothing to do with
this they're not
interested in politics they just want to
be successful live the american dream
uh put someone in office that's going to
protect them and help them thrive and
their babies and their future
and these are the people like you said
that want to continue on to live their
lives
and it's just our political arena right
now
is like you're like forced to get
involved because there's death threats
being made
you know the country's on the line the
constitution's on the line there's so
much freedom and liberty
that's on the line right now and even
people that are traditional liberals
people that have been on the left
they're identifying it's not the right
it's not the right that has it right
it's this is about good and evil now
this is about truth
and lies and this is about making sure
that our constitutional freedoms are
intact because if they're not
we have no future we have no future if
this
all falls and burns you don't think it
is or tonight
the people who are aligned with like
antifa on the left and the people who
would vote for joe biden
they they think first of all they have
no idea what's really going on
because i think if any of them spent any
amount of time researching watching
videos and watching a trump speech
they'd be like hey wait a minute
that wasn't true and that would change
their their
view all they know is things are scary
and they're being threatened and so
they've built this world view
but if they change that it'll take a lot
of work and it'll increase their risk
and they don't want to do that that's
why you have that bug-eyed woman
screaming at the black woman about how
she's the only one who can stop racism
or whatever
they they it's it's i guess
it's almost hysterical it's like a
hysteria among many of these people
yeah so you get the average person who's
watched a youtube video who reads the
news and they're going to have a more
moderate view of things
that's that's one you know one thing we
talk about like why why i'm
hopeful having so many people watch
shows like this and listen you know
listening to me because
i'm just kind of like i think i think
the whole thing is dude chill
you know i i think uh you know you know
fleccas
he had a great line way back when that's
like stuck with me trump's not that bad
he's like asking people like hey trump's
kind of bad right they're like yeah but
it's
not
that bad right and then people would
laugh and be like yeah he's not that bad
i'm like
that's an amazing line to explain to
people chill
dude trump isn't dropping nukes he's not
there's no there's no camps like this
stuff's made up or or if it did exist it
was like obama who was doing these
things too
and we need to reform this stuff but
trump is not the boogeyman
they think he is but that's why i told
you earlier tim i don't think you
realize what you mean to people
oh yeah because you're you're so
you're so s in the middle where people
can relate to you on so many levels
but what's important about that tim is
you're like anakin skywalker bro later
now
you're going to bring balance to the
force that's not a good thing you know
but you just got to make sure that you
don't go towards the dark side
you know i'm not saying you are anakin i
said you're like anakin
right and i'm being serious i'm being
dead serious right now in the culture
what you mean right now what this show
means right now is to bring balance
to everyone you're saying all i got to
do is kill a bunch of kids and i'll get
supreme power
oh they're going to cut that up flip it
already that's headlines
oh believe it don't slaughter the
padawans
okay don't slaughter the padawans i will
not be what anakin was meant to be
no no anakin was meant to destroy the
jedi yeah that
was don't they say this in the revenge
of the sith that perhaps they misread
the prophecy
he was going to bring balance to the
force by getting rid of almost every
jedi
no because there were only two sith and
there were thousands of jedi balance
meant the rule of two
yeah balance meant you can't create more
sith you can only get rid of jedi yeah
and he did well the emperor did yeah so
let me ask you man
you're riding in a car with these auntie
people what what is it like are they
normal people are they like you want
taco bell bro and you're like yeah let
me get a number two
well mike are they screaming like when
we get to taco bell man i'm gonna punch
trump oh man
they're very calm and collective before
they're gonna go and riot
yeah when i was in the car they're like
you good bro
i'm like yeah i'm good they're like
where uh where uh where where's everyone
at i'm like
oh they're over on that other street
like all right let's go let's go and
they're just very calm they're very
collected
but whenever they see police it's like
their brains
break this is like you know they go like
super saiyan
3 you know like literally super saiyan
how many people get that reference
you know i'm sure i'm sure thousands of
people get referenced dude like they
completely change
their hair grows their hair grows you
know turns gold like yours
it turns gold and you know i'm sorry to
my viewers about the gold hair there's a
reason for it i can't tell you why okay
you're going super saying that's but
they do they do they literally just
change they change into these crazy
people because they're emboldened when
they're in groups and they see police
officers and it just sets them off and
it's like they have like these they like
have orgasms dude
like when they see it and when they're
ready to just go in on it that's what
they do
like they just love it too much it's it
gives them a sense of purpose
yeah i've talked about this before you
know
i've i have a segment about it i think
this is why they want to kill me dude
the stuff i'm telling you guys tonight
is like
secret it's totally true but i'm saying
it in a way that's
comical but you guys need to take it
serious too for sure because
there's a reason why um they're being in
there they're they're investigated
there's a reason they are dangerous
i mean yeah look we got commander red
curling in the fetal position and crying
when he gets arrested why are they
releasing his flame yeah
yeah even though he had a flamethrower
i'll tell you man it's funny we left
this commander red guy but they let him
go
yeah they're like he jumped bail let's
bail him out again
cool that is and for a lower number
no wonder this this stuff keeps
happening do you see what you see what
they just did with the state police in
port in oregon
they deputized them federally wow you
know that means you get arrested by a
state trooper in oregon
it goes to the federal attorneys there
you go you're getting locked up yeah
dude people don't realize this man see
but that's the thing is we've gotten so
far away in our culture from consequence
and accountability right where people
when they don't see consequence
they're not held accountable if they
know that there will be no consequence
to any kind of action right whether it's
digital whether it's in the real world
whatever it is that emboldens me to go
and do something
because if i know if i'm antifa you know
i'm living in my mom's basement
right and i'm collecting those trump
stimulus checks that's probably what's
like funding a lot of these guys
if i'm living like that and i'm now
emboldened
if i know if i go out there and i could
throw a molotov cocktail
at a courthouse and i'm gonna get a slap
on the wrist they'll probably let me out
within the next two hours
yep i'm gonna keep doing it they're
bored it's it's there's no purpose
anymore
right think about the the the european
colonists
who are all like yo let's get on this
boat and then spend three months at sea
where half you know a good a good
portion of people will die and we'll
just get chucked overboard
and then when we finally make it to that
shore there's nothing there
and they're like yeah and they high-five
and they bring their families
i'm like wow people are crazy that's
crazy
the amount of risk dude you're gonna die
dude
you know what's crazy to me is i i i was
reading uh uh when i was at glenn beck's
studio there's a his really old
newspapers mounted on the wall
and one of them talks about how there's
uh a guy was outside of a bar
like a cigar bar or something and some
random walked up put a gun in his chest
and pulled the trigger
and i just like for no it was it was
like an old story from 1800s and i'm
like
you know a lot of these things still
kind of happen today especially in
chicago like random shootings
but when i when i look back a lot of
this old stuff man they were people were
really willy-nilly with their lives
like for me i'm very much like i i've
grown quite fond of living
i'd like to make sure that carrie's on
but i read these stories about people
who are like we're gonna get on this
boat we're gonna be gone for three
months likely starve or die of
dehydration maybe
get scurvy and then those of us that
make it have nothing but harsh realities
of no food
that was that was like people did it and
they came to they came they came to the
north america some people did bad stuff
a lot of people did bad stuff
and then they started building things
today nobody wants to do that
yeah so these these antifa types have no
purpose
yeah in their minds they have this
vision
here's what i imagine it's you know
imagine you know 100 years people people
don't realize about the colonial era
whatever you want whatever you want to
call it 1492 columbus sails the ocean
blue
we were it was hundreds of years
of uh you know of settlement in north
america
it was a really really really long time
before there was the american revolution
and
you know this country was formed but i
have to imagine there's somebody sitting
in london
in like 16 something or maybe like early
1700s being like
man this image of making it across the
ocean it's a dangerous journey it's
difficult it's expensive and
you're going to be an indentured servant
yeah and you you're imagining this great
open world of endless freedom and
discovery just
swaths of land and people haven't even
been to the other side of the continent
yet
you're like all this discovery waiting
there for me it's a beautiful utopian
view of adventure and life and
opportunity
and so they take that risk they get on
that boat they make it
today you've got a bunch of antifa
sitting in their mom's basements and i'm
purposely being you know disrespectful
and they're they're imagining in their
heads that great journey
is tearing down the government and
creating the communist utopia
but there is no country to go to they
there there's there is no communist
utopia
it's almost like you got you get
somebody sitting in there and you know
in the 1700s in london being like i want
to make it to atlantis
you're like bro if you get on that boat
looking for atlanta you're going to die
because there's no atlantis
and then who knows where you'll end up
you know it ends up happening you get in
a boat right now looking for atlantis
you're going to run out of food and
you're going to end up in some on some
if you get lucky enough on a deserted
island we're going to have resources and
life's going to suck
that's what the far left is doing they
think they're driving us towards the
great
law city of atlantis this beautiful
utopia instead
they're driving everything into a crater
where we're all we're all going to
suffer yeah and that's history repeating
itself
yeah because it's happened once it's
happened twice it's happened multiple
times in history
but right now what's different is the
united states of america and our
constitutional republic
is being used against itself it is very
very strategically and very very
successfully
because a lot of people will say well
it's it's it's my first amendment right
to you know stand outside and and
call for you know the murder of trump
supporters that that's where we're going
right and it's not and it's not
but that's where we are right now thanks
for checking out this clip from the tim
cast
irl podcast we do the show live monday
through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe
hit the like button hit the notification
bell and we are also available on all
podcast platforms for
free if you want to listen to us there
thanks for hanging out and we will see
you all next time